c'est une plongée au cœur de la bataille
sur ces images diffusées par les
garde-fontières Ukrainiens les combats
toujours en cours pour la conquête de
barmut ville où les mercenaires de
Wagner étaient les plus aguerris
la mitrailleuse entre en action mais le
danger lui est déjà ailleurs
caché en sous-sol cette officier
prévient ses frères d'armes un soldat
russe est en train de percer leur ligne
sa position est bombardée quelques
secondes plus tard
un exemple parmi tant d'autres de la
difficulté actuelle des Russes sur le
terrain
qui est fait formel depuis la rébellion
avortée du groupe Wagner et même si
volodime Hélène qui reconnaît que la
progression est plus lente que prévu ces
hommes reprennent des positions aux
Russes qui eux enchaînent les revers
ainsi que les troupes d'occupation
russes subissent des pertes importantes
en personnel en armes et en équipement
les soldats ukrainiens ont mené des
opérations offensives dans la direction
de darkmouth dans les zones des colonies
Dory rive vassiliveca
ivanivsquée cours de Mika et pivenais et
ils ont réussi à prendre pied dans ses
territoires des pertes significatives
selon les Ukrainiens il l'assure rien
que lundi près de barmut 153 soldats
russes sont morts et pas moins de 200
autres ont été blessés